GUNTHER ROLAND: So teamwork
is extremely important,
both in 8.13 and 8.14.
And again, that's one of
the things that many of them
really learn in Junior
Lab for the first time,
that they have the
partner and they really
have to figure out how to
make sure that the two of them
join forces in doing this.
So it's not just
dividing the work,
but really working together
to make the most out
of their time.
And I think it's really
the most successful teams
are the ones that
work closely together
and don't just meet in the lab
and then split up afterwards.
And I think impressing that
on the students, the value
of collaboration,
is one of the goals
that we have in 8.13
and then in 8.14.
At the beginning of 8.13, we
have lectures on collaboration
by one of the WRAP instructors.
And the students
at the beginning
are sometimes a little bit
bemused at these lectures,
because they spell out concepts
that seem rather natural.
But once this gets translated
into practice in 8.13,
I think--
I hope that the students realize
that these concepts really
are important for their work
and to be able to be reliable,
to be able to trust
the other person,
to be able to take criticism
from their partner,
to be able to really split
the work in an effective way,
but then also collaborate
on cross-checking
each other's work.
These are things that we
discuss at the beginning
and then try to
monitor continuously
throughout the semester.
And I find that, often, that the
students that find their time
management towards the end
of the semester the most
challenging are the
ones who didn't really
develop a good style
of collaboration
with their partner.
So this is sort of
one of the predictors
of what causes difficulties
towards the end
of the semester, when
many things come due
in a very short time.